peu de souffler ma chérie et G toi tu es
tu tu es tu es colère après qui oh après
Géraldine je vais me Vanger bien
regardez céit hier regardez les gars qui
sont posé des questions ils sont fait
ils sont fait Ken ils sont fait
dehors que ce soit Miriam que ce soit
d'AES mdecins que ce soit des poesque
alors parce que dans les manifestations
antipass ou antivaccin il y avait toute
bah il y avait toute la frange
[Musique]
antisémiteer tu es d' ridicule mais
alors insortable
an son antisémit
non c'est une pe fille je pe la laisser
dire ça c'est dégueulasse de dire ça
Jérôme Rodriguez que j'embrasse me dit
s'il y avait que sur les réseaux mais
dans la rue et au café et toute la
journée on a parlé que de Géraldine
Géraldine Géraldine galdine c'est
vraiment voilà c'est c'est un truc de
fou tout le monde était sur les côtes de
galdine ma Maus maaré en latin mai qui
veut dire vaccin en égyptien Gérard
etpine merci d'être avec nous merci à
vous vous êtes bien élégant non si bon
ta femme s'est occuper de moi et ben
écoutez vous avez bien raison
profitez-en elle sait que vous elle vous
regarde ce soir ah elle me regarde
jamais non c'est vrai ah ou ah non
jamais en direct elle a peur non elle a
regardé hier l'émission avec vous vous
avez vu les vous avez vu hier les les
propos de geraline ma je sais non mais
je les ai vu en différé ouais et alors
qu'est-ce que vous qu'est-ce que vous
dites bah je trouve que malheureusement
Géraldine a fait d'abord une erreur de
terme en parlant d'antivax pour les gens
qui étaient contre le covid contre les
injections du covid tout simplement
parce que les injections covid n'ont
jamais été des vaccins je sais bien
qu'ils ont été appelés par comme ça par
toutes les médias mais moi je je suis
très fidèle à Pasteur hein et pasteur
explique un vaccin on prend oui je la
définition de pasteur un vaccin c'est un
germe atténuer ou casser en petits
morceau pour donner des antigènes et on
injecte des antigènes c'est comme ça
qu'on crée une imunité spécifique or
dans les soi-disants injections covid
qui n'ont jamais été des vaccins c'est
été utilisé uniquement pour les faire
vendre et les faire accepter par la
population il n'y avait strictement
aucun antigène ok il y avait seulement
un ARN qui vous permettait de fabriquer
se passe comme prévu mais oui c'est la
vérité c'est l'ennui de la vérité c'est
qu'elle est parfaitement vérité est
ailleursérité non peut-être ailleurs de
votre esprit qu'est-ce que vous a choqué
dans ce qu' dit Géraldine maillet et ben
donc elle a premièrement dit une erreur
en parlant d'antivax quand on est anti
injection covid alors que moi par
exemple j'étais fortement contre les
injections covid contre le confinement
contre les masques et tout ça sur des
éléments médicaux et sur des faits
établis alors donc ça n'était pas un
vaccin premièrement
deuxièmement dans donc on devait pas
appeler les antivaxes mais peut-être des
vaccinos prudents moi je suis je défends
la vaccination la vraie vaccination
celle qui est utile aux gens et ce qui
m'agace dans cette affaire c'est que
cette soi-disant injection était
extrêmement toxique et non sauvé
personne donc c'est pour ça que je ne
veux pas qu'on traite ces choseslà de
vaccin car c'est le plus mauvais exemple
qu'on peut donner de vaccination parce
que qu'est-ce qu'ont vu les gens dans
les faits autour d'eux c'est des gens
vaccinés revaccinés à jour de leur
rappel faisait quand même la maladie
c'est que maintenant les gens qui sont
les plus malades ce sont que ceux qui
ont eu qure ou C injection donc il y a
un vrai problème alors en fait vous avez
pas vu l'émission non l'émission je m'en
fous bah alors ouais je suis pas je suis
pas sage docteur non mais par contre
j'ai revu j'ai revu les les les rappels
les meilleurs moments les petites
séquences un peu tronquées comme ça
peutêtre tronqué est-ce que vous avez
est-ce que vous êtes d'accord
avec estce vous AZ aller trop loin alors
moi en revanche je n'ai traité personne
de pauvre idiote moi je n'ai pas é non
non dis parce que hier on m'a traité de
pauvre idiote je n'insulte jamais
personne de la même manière je n'ai pas
la misogymie et et le mépr du professeur
raou qui m'a balayer d'un revers de
manche je parle pas je ne parle pas à
des gens comme vous bon bref donc est-ce
que je suis allé trop loin euh non je ne
crois pas que je suis allée trop loin
hier et je pense queeffectivement ça
n'était pas le sujet au départ quand
nous avons parlé de du du du beau livre
et du beau témoignage de Nathalie
Marquet mais quand on est allé plus loin
après on a dit on a balayé d'un rever de
manche en disant oui mais pourquoi on
utilise ce terme de complot de complot
de complot de complot et voilà et
pourquoi on utilise ce terme de complot
aussi parce que effectivement dans ces
manifestations il y avait une frange
malgré tout antisémite il s'agit et
encore une fois ce n'est pas un je ne
fais pas un amalgame je je
l'essentialise pas je ne dis pas que
tous ceux qui sont contre ce vaccin sont
des préciser cé
cl ça n'était pas clair hier je suis pas
le seul r ça s enflammé c'est que ça
nétait pas clair auj'hui pas V
aujourd'hui c'est plus cl non non non
mais même des gens qui ont vu l'émission
je le sais
je bien se victimiser pour après
m'assassiner en disant en gros oui elle
dit toujours la même chose et ben
écoutez encore une fois replongez-vous
dans les archives de de et encore une
fois hier cy j'étais pas d'accord avec
vous vous disz oui mais les antisémites
ça va c'est quelques con mais non en
fait encore une fois non non non non non
non non l'antisémitisme c'est pas des
cons par on va pas parler
d'antisémitisme ce so dis non non c'est
c'est vos term
qui vous maintenz minutes je vous dis là
là vous dites écoutez-moi bien je vous
dis vous dites n'importe quoi on parle
de gens qui ont été mis ont été ont été
mis de côtés parce qu'ils ont été ils
sont posé des questions c'est ce qu'on a
dit ici on n pas parlé d'antisémitisme
de voilà et donc vous vous avez mis oui
mais à chaque fois vous mettez ça sur le
tapis ça n' rien à voir on fera un débat
si vous voulez làdessusant n pas le
débat c'est pas le débat ça n rien à
voirpémies des grandes
pémiesais le grand
Ju
vous vous arrêtez sur quelquesul Berl
qui disent des
bêtis on fera ce débat si vous voulez
mais arrêtez toujours de vouloir aller
sur ce débat parce que vous avez
pasargum sur le débat vousz pas
d'argument sur l'histoire des antiv
pas d'abord je voulais vous remercier
parce que j'ai croisé toute la bande en
coulisse vous m'avez gâté on a la crème
de la
crème ça va être magnifique vous voulez
pas parler de ça mais je regrette tout
le monde a été témoin non pas une fois
10 fois 100 fois 1000 fois que non pas
tous les antivages sont antisémites mais
ils sont manipulés et animés par des
antisémites ce n'est pas Géraldine qui a
inventé je ne suis pas manipulé
j'examine les faits et je publie les
faits par oui mais c'est pas une raison
n pas ce n pas Géraldine qui a inventé
les pancartes me qui me qui c'est un
signe de ralliment antisémite qui veut
dire qui manipule la société ce sont les
Juifs est-ce que oui ou non une femme a
même été interpellé pour avoir brandi
cette pancarte ù n'était mentionné que
des nonjuifs
oui arrivé 100 fois 1000 fois 100
fois000 fois pas 100 fois c'est
n'importe quoi de
fois moi je ba dans les théor du compl
vous êes docteur
d'ailleurs radié ah non certainement pas
il y a pas eu une enquête sur vous bon
certainement mais sont partis 30 ans que
certains veulent des enquêtes sur moi
ils sont tous partis la que basse alors
j'ai pas peur des ça quelque chose merci
j'ai pas dit d'autre chose j'ai pas dit
comment vous dérange pas qu'on vous
répond dans les théories du complot il
est toujours question des rootchield à
un moment non mais c'est vous qui
inventez les complots c'est vous qui
inventez les complot moi j'ai dit tout
simplement le vaccin n'est pas un vaccin
il est pas efficace et il tue c'est tout
je vis vous dire là là le débat me fait
chier parce que vous êtes sur à côté de
la plaque je veux et même la question la
question n'est pas bonne la question
n'est même pas bonne dis moi on parl des
qui se sont posés des questions les
antivax qui sont posé des questions ou
même pas les antivax les gens qui sont
posés des questions qui ont ét et qui
ont étéandaleusement mis de
[Musique]
côté les antivax ne veulent pas entendre
les vaccin prudents ont été éjectés de
leur métier comme on a jeté les Juifs
sous
ré la prière chose fait la prière
décision de l'ordre des
médec qui ex les médecs Juifs bien l're
M
mdecs Monsieur le Représentant des
manifest ah oui qui qui défilait avec
des étoiles jaunes c'était les antivax
qui osaient se comparer au
juifs il y a des juif d'Israël qui ont
défilé avec l'étoile jaune vous l'z
l'air d'avoir oublié ses images moi je
les j'aimerais qu'on qu'on rentrer
Florian Philippo qui aussi voilà à côté
de surt beso d'AC voil non non mais
attendez s'il vous plaît non mais le
truc P il faut parler des faits vous
n'avez pas du tout ême du vaccin du
soi-disant vaccin covid qui n'a jamais
été un vaccin et qui a fait des dégâts
et qui a sauvé personne cétait la seule
région et accuser les gens de raconter
cel 99% de la communauté scientifique
est en désaccord avec vousez des
questionsct docteur écoutez lisez un peu
les articles ça vous fera le plus grand
bienésidentat ça c'est votre droit si
vous voulez arrê
là